Hello everyone.
We are Vega. We're a start-up started
in January 2024.
We raised $65 million from
cyberstarts, Acel, Wetpoint, and.
To completely change how you
do security operations and
security analytics,
um, and today we're gonna talk
about how you can reimagine
your SIM architecture using
AWSS for buckets,
something that we all have today,
and how you can increase your
visibility and get a lot
more out of your data
without compromising on costs
and breaking the bank.
So, um.
Just a bit on us, I'm Ellie. I'm
the co-founder and CTO here at Vega.
Uh, I've been building Vega together with a
team for, uh, almost two years,
since January 2024.
I'm based in New York, originally from Tel
Aviv.
I've been doing cybersecurity for more
than 15 years. Started on the
offensive side,
uh, and now on the defensive side.
Actually did a lot of, uh, uh,
low-level engineering, which is gonna,
uh, show up in, uh, the talk today.
And also Iran.
Uh, hi everyone. Uh, my name is Ian, head
of, uh, threat detection and research at
Vega. Uh, past 10 years, roughly
doing incident response, uh, threat hunting,
managed the SOC
in the past,
uh, led engagements, uh,
of incident response in a global
IR firm,
and today at Vega for
around 1 year and a half years.
Perfect. So really when we started
Vega, um, we spoke with
hundreds of enterprises
and we asked them and
spoke with them about their challenges
today that they're facing with their SIM and
their security operations programs.
Um, and really we have, we've identified
three common problems
amongst almost every customer that we
spoke with.
The first one is growing security
telemetry volume
and with.
You know, migration to the cloud today and
multi-cloud environments,
the types and volumes of security telemetry
just grows year over year and
you know, significantly grows, and you
have cloud logs, VPC flow logs,
you have all these logs that you want to
be able to generate security insights
from them,
but it's really challenging. It's really
challenging many times because of
the cost constraints
that are coming with the traditional
architecture of the same.
And really if you think about,
you know, the traditional monolithic architecture
requires you to send all these logs
and pay for each byte of log
that you're sending into your SIM
and therefore you have to deal with all
these cost constraints. Um,
another common problem that we've seen
amongst
every organization or a lot of
organizations is as a result of the growing data
volume as well as the cost constraints,
we've seen a lot of organizations who just
keep. Multiple data repositories
of their security telemetries.
Maybe they have some in each cloud
environment. Maybe
they have a bunch of different SIMs. We've seen
organizations with 9 different SIMs
and uh different data lakes,
and think about how you can deal with that.
Um, and
All of these, uh, uh,
uh, you know,
uh, problems really stem
from
The outdated monolithic
architecture of the SIM,
which requires organizations
and leads, you know,
engineers and, and the security
operations teams
to work with some assumptions
of, uh, you know, what you can
do and what you should do with your, with
your security telemetries.
And the most important
assumption that we are challenging at
Vega. Is
telemetry,
security telemetry centralization.
And we're asking ourselves,
why
do you need to centralize and copy
each byte of data
that you would like to be able to monitor on?
Uh, why can't you just query
data in multiple data repositories
instead of sending it all over the
internet, uh,
uh, into this one centralized data
location? Another one is.
Why the storage and detection,
engineering and threat hunting capabilities
must be coupled into the same
uh monolithic system.
Just like how, uh, uh, you know, we've
seen data technologies that decouple
storage and compute.
Why? Security
operations teams have to rely on
a single monolithic piece
that couples together their storage
and the storage fees
together with the security processes
and outcomes that they want
out of this security data.
And really it also we're asking
the question of
why cannot you utilize
multiple
uh uh uh data repositories
and storages, uh, maybe
even your S3 buckets
to achieve the outcomes that you
would like out of a traditional
SIM, uh, querying the data,
correlating the data.
And what happens really when you have
multiple data repositories?
Maybe uh uh that's due to
MNA.
Maybe you've acquired a new company
and they have another SIM.
Maybe as a result of data residency
requirements, you have to keep data in multiple
data repositories.
But uh, you still want to be
able to cross correlate.
Uh, data across all these different repositories
and even, you know, either build
an a detection,
right, on top of this data, maybe do some
threat hunting
or respond to a real incident and
you would like to be able to query all this
data.
Fundamentally,
You know, those outdated
architectural assumptions that are coming
with the monolithic architecture of the same
really, uh, uh, uh, you know,
uh, make
the threat detection team as well as the architecture
team, uh, uh, you
know, it's, it's a huge challenge to
solve these,
uh, problems with the traditional tools
that we have today. And let's talk
about how it affects real,
uh, AWS customers today.
OK, so we can take uh A
address as a, as an example how
to uh leverage um a
federated architecture
to achieve security operations.
So, uh let's see, uh, there's
an organization they want to,
uh, monitor and apply, uh,
detections and threat hunting
and incident response over their AWS
environment.
So for that, first of all, they gotta enable
those logs. They are cloud trails, VPC
flow logs, guard duty.
So there's a fee of course
for AWS to enable those services.
Those services are
creating logs and audits, and those logs
need to be retained. So we have the AWS
storage,
that's your cloud watch, your S3
buckets.
So you have the service creating
the logs. You have now the storage there,
but the team cannot really leverage those logs
for any security purposes when they're
simply retained
in that storage.
So what they gotta do in the, you know, the,
the, the old fashioned way as we call it, they gotta
send it to the SIM. So they gotta uh
start shipping all the logs from AWS
outside of Amazon and into their SIM. So
this is leading for AWS egress
costs.
For data movement,
then we have the most significant
cost for the SIM ingestion
and also the SIM storage because you want
to retain it for a long period of time
and most most SIM solutions
today. Of course,
um,
you need to also apply security modules
and this, this costs additional costs, meaning
that if a security team
wants to go ahead and have
uh security operation capabilities
on top of your AWS environment, they
gotta have 6 places where they're actually
spending money
just to do this simple thing.
Imagine there's an
organization with 200, 400,
even 750 ES accounts,
uh, and how much
money just cost just to get the
data to where they can start leveraging
it. So, uh, with
this example, this is what we're, um,
one example of one thing we're coming to,
to, to fix and, and address,
uh, in our federated approach.
So, uh, let's see how this looks like, for
example, when we do not
ship the logs to the SIM.
So, we got the, of course, the
service, so we gotta enable those logs.
Uh, we gotta store them,
so in the database storage,
but that's it.
What basically we're doing, we're applying
an indexer
to index those logs exactly
where they already are, where they natively
already live.
So we're using
uh indexing computes in the same
cloud,
in the same region
to take those logs in,
let's say S3 buckets
and create an index for them in the same storage.
So we're, we're able to achieve
that index without chipping the logs
outside of AWS.
The second part of this, of, of
this process is to be able to run queries,
threat hunting, incident response, detections,
and that's where,
uh, Vega is a console.
Um, which is external is able
to reach out to that storage, to that index,
and do queries, do federated
detections, do instantent response, and essentially
everything a security need a team would need
to, um,
uh, to, to, to do detection and response over
AWS.
So we just have some
service fees, the storage, the 3 buckets,
some, some computes, but it's a
small fraction of the
money it actually costs
when you don't need to ship it.
So in this scenario, an organization with
let's say 750+
HDBS accounts that can achieve
these security operation capabilities
with 60
up to 80%
cost reduction.
By doing this approach,
so there's no what we call syntax.
Uh, let's see 22 use cases,
an example. Uh, with
two organizations that we're working with who
are using
S3 buckets,
um, to, to, um,
to use the federated architecture.
So one is a major e-commerce platform.
They essentially had a seam solution that they
use for everything they need,
but they also needed to have a longer retention
period, so they're shipping everything
to S3 buckets just as a backup.
When we started a conversation with them, we just told
them, listen, all your logs are already
in a, in a very low cost,
high performance storage.
But you're also sending it to the SIM and it costs
you so much money.
So essentially we're, we started
to index all their logs, their firewall,
EDR,
Office 365,
any data source that they have in estuary buckets.
We just applied indexing for it exactly where it
is. This made their
SIM entirely redundant
because they were able to create detections on top of the S3
threat hunting on top of S3 incident
response the same,
so they were able to churn and entirely remove
the SIM and the immediate value
was a 70% cost reduction in
total.
Um, they have the same
security capabilities but even more than
that because now that they have this additional cost
they're able to say, right, so now I can have
longer retention periods of my
data. I can onboard more
data that I could not have onboarded before.
Let's say I can have a load balancer logs or waf
logs or the EDR event telemetry,
something that I say I cannot really fit in my SIM,
but now that I have this extra money plus the
capability to operationalize data in a low,
in a low cost, high performance storage, now
it's an opportunity for them.
Uh, the second use case is a Fortune 500
pharmaceutical company.
They had a very,
very large SIM.
Um, really dozens of terabytes per
day. And at some point
they realized that they cannot afford
to send all the logs from AWS
to their SIM
just because of, of, of
the insane amount of costs
of uh that it takes.
So they were looking for a solution to
uh have security operations on top of
their AWS without
shipping it to the SIM.
So, uh, we came in, we started to index
all their, uh, they have a 500 or more
than 500 AWS accounts. So we started to index
their cloud trail, VPC flow logs, guard duty,
cloudWatch, any piece of data, RDS logs,
everything they needed for the security day to day.
Uh, they gained full visibility, all
detection capabilities on top of it, but
did not ship a single log out of Amazon.
Everything solely rela uh there,
no egress cost at all, no syntax,
um, but then you can say,
but I have an issue now.
I have logs
for my security team
in S3.
But also have logs for security
in the SIM, so practically what happened
there is data fragmentation.
Practically what happened here is the security teams
need to work on two consoles, and this is what we
wanted to avoid.
So Vega also have that capability to
go ahead and connect to an existing
SIM,
also an existing data lake,
and also to object storage
and cross correlate information that does
not exist in the same place.
One more slide
So there are 3 core.
Things that we're um
focusing on. The first one is the capability
to to have a correlation cross
storage. If I have logs in S3,
logs in my SIM, log in my Elastic,
logs in my Snowflake, logs in other
cloud platforms, I can still run one
query that is taking these logs and these logs
and cross correlating it, so the fragmentation
becomes irrelevant.
The second thing is hybrid data lakes,
meaning that I can have
uh data lake, let's call it the S3 I
can have something which is the elastic and I I
can have the SIM.
So different data lakes of different technologies
of different even query languages, but
it would still work seamless.
And the third thing.
Is to still keep a unified
security view, meaning one platform, a
true real,
uh, single pane of glass,
even though I have different data lakes, it's still
11 console, one query
language,
and just one interface to work in for the
team and let's see how, uh, let's see
how this looks like at a high level.
So you must, must be asking
yourself how does this magic work behind the
scenes.
So this is
basically what we've been working on
for the last two years.
And we call it SEM, Security Analytics
Smash.
Now, the architecture
of security analytics Smash
really gives you the flexibility
of connecting to the data
wherever it makes sense to keep the
data. And you must be asking
yourself, well, now I have to rip and replace my
existing SIM.
But no, as everyone said,
one of the core capabilities of Vega
is understanding that you already
have made a lot of investments
in your EDR platform, in your
existing SIM platform,
in maybe a data lake where you're shipping
some of your logs. Maybe you're using a pipeline
tool like a Quibble
to push them to ask for buckets.
Vega can help
instantly operationalize all
of these data repositories
uh uh without moving all the data.
So we can connect to any
SIM,
Splank, Microsoft Sentinel, Google
Setups, Elastic.
We can connect to any NextGen SIM
and XDL platforms like the
Sentinel One Data Lake or the CrowdStrike
NextGen SIM.
And all of the telemetries
that you already have in there, they
can stay in there, and over time,
if you feel like it makes sense for you to
move them to S3 buckets or a data
lake,
it's up to you. You now have the
flexibility to choose where you want
to store your data.
Now, but the real power of Vega
comes
when uh uh we talk about data
lakes and object storage.
So we can connect to also
data lakes such as data bricks
or Snowflake. And if your CIO
decides that, you know, you guys
are going all in on a specific data lake,
that's fine. That should not change
uh how the security team is
working or building and managing detections.
But most importantly for AWS
customers,
Vega shines if you have a lot
of data already in object storage.
And if you think about most of the
telemetries that are born in the cloud, or basically
all of the telemetries that are born in the cloud,
they are naturally born in object storage.
Vega allows you to keep
all the cloud logs and the VPC
flow logs
within those object storage. What we
do is we have our own indexing
technology where you don't need to ship the
data to any data lake or or
a SIM. We can connect and index
the data
within the same cloud and within the same region.
This architecture makes so much
more sense
because there is no need to send data all
over the internet.
Now, think about a multi-cloud
uh environment.
Maybe you're using multiple clouds.
We have a customer who is
utilizing all three major clouds
across tens of regions, and they have
thousands of cloud
accounts across each
each cloud provider.
With them we can instantly operationalize
all of their data
in the. The data locally,
save a lot of money. This
can come up to millions of dollars and even
tens of millions of dollars, but still
achieve all the security outcomes
that they want
and get visibility
out to all of the security telemetries.
Also, you have much more power
because you can be in control over
your own indexes. You can keep
the indexed
buckets
in your AWS account.
So now you have more attention,
more flexibility to where you want to put
your data,
and less cost.
Sounds good to me.
Um,
really, all of these data repositories
are are accessible for a single KQL
query interface.
So our user interface and user experience
is very good.
People love it and especially analysts
who are already familiar with the pipeline language
like SPL or Microsoft Sentinel's
KQL we leverage the same KQL
so it's easy to get started instantly,
um, uh uh and, and
get your sock uh to be familiar
with the system.
We also obviously leverage a lot of AI
and LLM capabilities within the product
to, to make, uh, uh, uh,
asking simple questions really easy.
And I think the most important piece is
that this is the foundation
for an AI native security
operations, because once you have this single semantic
data layer across all of your
security telemetries in every data repository,
you can now achieve the AI outcomes
that you want out of your data, because we all
know that your
AI triage, AI detections,
AI ability to
respond to threats is only as good to
be, is only as good as the data
that the AI and LLM can
access. Now we're almost out of
time, but uh if you
would like to chat more, we'll be at our booth
1928.
We're also gonna give some hotdogs.
So uh I would love to see you there and chat, chat
about your same challenges and how Vega can help.
Thank you.